зупиниться якщо ми чули про яйця по 17
То тепер не почуємо навіть якщо будуть
закуповуватися яйця фбрже цим
голосуванням їм хотяти закрити рота це є
питання життя нашої країни ще раз про
рахункову палату України чи не єдиної
яка залишилася не в підпорядкуванні
офісу президента адже саме рахункова
палата проводить аудит всіх державних
установ ну наприкладкористання
міністерством оборони який підтвердив
зловживання і корупцію цим відомством
нас дуже дивує те
що нинішній склад укомплектовується
доукомплектовується таким поспіхом у
Верховній Раді
розглядалися до
укомплектування членів рахункової палати
порушення домовленості тому що
напередодні буквально посли Великої
сімки заявили про те що ви можете
дообирати членів рахункової палати після
зміни в законодавство які проблеми в
першу чергу зараз вирішує Україну
Це є оборона це є збереження
фінансування для існування держави і це
є
євроінтеграція повірте мені що цей
проект призначення членів рахункової
палати в супереч
пропозицій G7 Європейського Союзу б'є і
по першому і подругому І по-третьому які
зміни вони саме пропонували для того
щоби конкурсом відбором займалася е
професійна профільна е комісія яка би
створена була із фахівців які можуть
дати оцінку кожному кандидату Кожен член
рахункової палати має мати грунтовні
знання щодо фінансових всіх законів
починаючи від елементарного закону про
бухгалтерську облік і фінансову
звітність і решта всіх законів в Україні
тому зараз коли ви намагаєтесь
протягувати людей які будуть пособниками
фальсифікації висновків Я дуже здивована
при такій безпрецедентній фінансовій
підтримці з боку міжнародних партнерів
прозорість використання коштів справді
має бути на високому рівні так точно як
і використання коштів платників податків
в тому числі громадян України не можна
обирати тих аудиторів тих членів
рахункової палати яким в подальшому не
буде довіри і від громадянського
суспільства і від наших партнерів якщо
ми говоримо про прозорість використання
коштів про те що контроль ма має
здійснюватися компетентними людьми дайте
відповідь на просте питання Чи можемо ми
довіряти
аудитору який не знає своєї справи який
не може надати повної вичерпну
інформацію відповідно до закону в рамках
якого він діє я не маю досвіду
проведення аудиту державних установ саме
тому я зараз звертаю вашу увагу на те
яким чином як відбувається конкурсний
відбір членів рахункової палати що таке
державний аудит його а значить
фінансовий і
аудит який підскажіть У нас ще є У нас є
різні аудити у нас є і консолідований
аудит у нас є фінансовий аудит у нас є
аудит відповідності е ефективность
ефективності аудит Скажіть мені будь
ласка як профільний комітет Комітет з
питань бюджету де немає фахівців Які би
достеменно або навіть
якимось чином
орієнтувалися
в в правилах в процесах в регламенті
аудиту який має здійснювати рахункова
палата як вони можуть
відбирати кандидатів для того щоби далі
по процедурі і висувати рекомендувати їх
в Верховній Раді і за них голосувати як
політики можуть обирати професійну
людину Я вважаю що цього разу ми як
бюджетний
комітет зробили максимум щоб забезпечити
максимально прозорий і відкритий конкурс
дійсно є питання чи варто зараз
призначати членів рахункових рахункової
палати Але це вже Інше питання це
політичне питання ми маємо розуміти що
коли обира розглядалася кандидатура
Ольги піщанської
ну іншого виходу членів комітету як
підтримати її кандидатуру і
запропонувати розглянути в залі
Верховної Ради іншим народним депутатам
не було бо всі знають її наближеність до
родини президента просто щоб зробити
головою рахункової палати цю піщанську
наближену до родини зеленських на її
сестру оформлене вілер знають яким чином
вона була на попередній посаді нагадаю
головою антимонопольного
комітету абсолютно усвідомлював що не
маючи ніяких здобутків на попередній
роботі вони вимушені висувати цю людину
в подальшому і ще й пропонувати її
призначити головою рахункової палати
Нащо це все робити буде чергова ганьба
зупиниться Мені здається що ми тут маємо
всі задуматися тому що якщо ми чули про
яйця по 17 То тепер не почуємо навіть
якщо будуть закуповуватися яйця фбрж Чим
же пов'язана атака рау на рахункову
палату і спроба зняти або
дестабілізувати її роботу рахункова
палата вскрила корупцію в міністерстві
оборони рахункова палата найшла і
підтвердила яйцяпі 17 40 млрд дебіторки
рахункова палата скрила корупцію з
телесеріалами рахункова палата вскриває
і вскриває і на сьогоднішній день цим
голосуванням їм хотяти закрити рота І це
є найголовніше завдання яке ставить
перед собою влада і офіс президента
знайти людину яка більше ніколи не
розкриє інформацію яка стане відо відома
єдиній структурі яка має можливості
права і
обов'язки
перевіряти раціональність витрачання
коштів кожним міністерством кожною
інституцією І до речі ще і державни
підприємствами і якщо ми дойдемо до цих
питань Мені здається що там дуже багато
виникне інформації яка сколихне все все
суспільство тому і з таким поспіхом і з
таким напором здійснюється до добір
кандидатів і вибір голови рахункової
палати яка може бути довіра до людини
яка обиралася поспіхом в порушення
домовленостей з партнерами в порушення
домовленостей які призведуть до затримки
фінансування держави нашого бюджету і до
виживання країни в цілому ви почули про
те що я сказала прозорість підзвідність
і надання повної неупередженої
інформації нашим партнерам - це є
питання життя нашої країни